[Music]
what is up everybody hey purge here
joined by David today a little bit of
late start but it's all good we're here
that's what matters and today we are
playing dread out to dry not one came
out like six years ago long time ago
dried out two is here and actually came
out I believe on Friday got pushed back
a little bit there was some technical
difficulties let it game breaking bugs
over the weekend that was discovered by
the community and this morning they
released a patch to fix all that so now
I feel like no time better than the now
to check it out
so yeah let's do I'm a hop over to the
game screen we're gonna get it poppin
real quick so fresh game starting a new
new game here I never played this before
so that's also gonna be interesting I
think some weird things going on trying
to plug in the controller here and use
the controller if worse comes to worse
we could just switch places and all yeah
there we go
some save data I wonder if I should have
looked at the button layout first but
yeah what's up Brandon welcome
beetlejuice fj in the chat what is a
culture believe that photographs can
steal a person's soul and well we're all
ruined
[Laughter]
oh boy we got the gastro system
digestive system oh damn yeah dread out
its back now I don't know if the
storyline from this one is like a direct
continuation from the first one or not
so I'm not sure at all so we're gonna
find out all I seen was her zapping some
monsters with a smartphone and I was
like souls she looks like the girl from
life a strange I want to say kind of
what up wolf and do and Leon oh yeah
definitely
money oh it's very dark already
not my vibe haha alright let me press
some buttons here someone lost in
hangman over there and they were real
salty about it look at that Linda must
die die die
dang oh this looks like people died for
sure
guys I hope you all rest in peace all
right for sure damn poor one out
whoo but I bet you what but you what oh
no I need to be careful how I move this
because yeah
all right oh yeah like a school where
are my shoes no shoes yeah so I guess
I'm a school girl
all right I know the first one was like
similar bros school girl on a field trip
dark dude there's minimal lights my
wristwatch was glowing Oh was it
glow-in-the-dark that's kinda like a
flashlight
[Music]
okay great gamer how's everything going
man again be better look at us like
we're you know all of our friends are
dead
yeah someone's laughing at us my phone
phone has no warrant they destroyed my
bag but my phone survived an ordinary
budget and you had very durable phone
that does not look like a smart phone
become a media to channel her powers
okay
budget phone and long-lasting batteries
out there all right
it's a medium we're gonna channel some
powers I wasn't so there are ghosts yeah
I get your fatal frame gun yeah just
appeared press X activate flashlight
what are you looking at over there no
don't stop like that that's uh Oh Oh
who's that let me take your phone away
do they still appear there okay um hello
are you talk to him buddy
okay Wow okay now I feel less bad for
this guy because they're already messing
with us
so I got a locker I dislike grammars
really yes I think that it's um like an
out of Andre Oh fine Dre yo Dre
mommy no we're gonna go oh man that's
how you know you're scared and you start
crying for mommy that's true fear that
oh the hoods boy look your apps on your
phone yeah okay you can see like your
battery and stuff to your yeah I get
signal this is almost like Nintendo
format where B is like a and then a
piece I keep hitting the opposite ones
you're already here oh nice thanks
inventory oh my phone
no image is sticking yet all right have
any messages can't launch no friends
here goes to pedia a ghost pedia you
look up urban legends nice soon all
right words I can't are you still here
alright so now we got to go find Andre
and get this key yeah this thing better
have a long-lasting battery considering
you're using the flash and camera Dre
where you at
I was a lot hotter as I thought eat it
with my flash so that's the door we need
the Keith bar oh wait no the music
stopped I don't like that
alright the music's back that means that
came back for pizza pruning gaming's
asking if this is an early access it
just released this past weekend and also
they just released a patch update today
to fix some bugs so fresh out the gate I
know a lot of people are waiting for and
they didn't really know in the official
releases coming so yeah but it's out
official and what's it out on is it just
on Steam on Steam okay and right now
it's on sale actually for like $17.99 so
okay okay okay okay that's messed up
that's messed up I was trying to test
something and then it got real spooky I
am she was in this locker like she was
in a LAN not this one specifically yes
I'm hearing stuff and like now it's
getting creepy a bat it was definitely
set the don't
9 yo Dre I just need to Kehoe me so I
can get out and what the hell are you
dog this is really messed up I think
that's where I came from super scary
they're definitely setting me up right
now for sure for sure I know the second
I open this and the ghost does show up
on the screen I'm gonna lose it
seven seven seven seven seven seven
seven are you guys remember that I might
need that later or maybe I should take a
picture of there's just seven sevens
well the crickets ain't scared that's
for sure is there a button to quickly
turn around let me see oh I think so
then everyone everyone in chat is saying
like there's something behind you like
this often I press a bunch of buttons
and I didn't see I didn't see a 180
button in there so far
maybe they'll tell me at some point yeah
if there is one
I feel like that's part of the scare
factor is cuz like you turn around and
the light doesn't fully follow you just
yet yeah I don't even want to turn
around this is my proof
i seent it okay honestly I don't think
this is anything this is just something
there for the scary factor dude well you
think that and then watch gone yeah it's
gonna disappear
oh is that see-through I know I was like
kind of look like I could see through
that but I think it's just the texture
[Music]
yeah it was they're setting me up
there's Eddie we have something really
is about to go down to the music really
doesn't have I don't know if I'm
supposed to be looking through the
camera more or not
yo Andre where you at right now under
your planes ooh my trade plane do you
see what's going on here
[Music]
oh wait oh I know where I'm supposed to
go remember I couldn't walk in here
earlier because it was super dark ah now
I can see this part so that's also locks
also locks something's in here important
for all this to be locked and none of
the other ones right because we haven't
seen any items yet but I feel like
there's gotta be something there but I'm
not I'm like not noticing a health bar
anything yeah I don't know how that
works out
I feel like Andrea is probably somewhere
really easy bro Andres somewhere stupid
that's for sure alright that's where I
started okay okay check out this room
nope
Akash is asking to the school cabinets
and the classrooms have anything I don't
know I don't think we were able to
interact with them right um I didn't try
it but right at the start she did walk
out of one so wait let me check my
inventory right oh well so she's hiding
somewhere inside the classroom so we
just gotta go oh so he probably was in
one of those that yeah alright on Jay
he's scared
I get it yeah he's good kasia's ask is
that grandpa's machine no I'm not
grandfather itchy I am young in Dave
grandpa Ritchie is working on a very
important
yeah it's me oh you said thank God I'm
okay after y'all were just messing with
me
she's turning psycho oh man
so that must be her the one who's on a
white shadow was chasing me I'm too
scared to open this closet sorry
oh wait I know what I can do I'm gonna
tell him it was this I wasn't telling
him it was just oh wow I'll take it back
because remember I did take a picture of
that thing didn't I oh no I took photos
you you looked at it through your phone
and then you put it down I'm gonna take
a picture of yeah I think that thing and
tell him there's nothing chasing you
it's just that all right okay
nothing to worry about Andre was just a
blanket you good I'm not gonna tell him
about the first thing we saw cuz then
he's really not gonna believe ya you
know mega boys asking fatal frame and
that's yeah I mean that's definitely the
thought right can't show it so can you
I feel like maybe you have to find that
a white shat on just like oh yeah come
at me bro why are you scaring Andre over
here scarin me dude I still feel like
this thing is the key to getting him to
think that nature's financing there's
something on the floor you're able to
enter a question mark what is that noise
I know you don't want this to be louder
but I need some all right so we'll look
in all the cabinets
yeah he's got a search around not that
one didn't interact that one
go if I am buddy again alright let me go
back to budding maybe help you talk to
buddy he'd be a story where's my get hey
you know what the cat hasn't steered me
wrong yet music has about Alicia she's
gone
oh whoa whoa what was that what what
just happened was that cuz I ran into
the tree maybe but you just scared the
[ __ ] you know what I think I'm supposed
to hit it with the I think I'm supposed
to I did I think I got a picture of it
Oh oh my guess
[Music]
hold up I need to see that photo I don't
think it was enough
on the kiddies Oh No so okay so the cast
just your marker basically like letting
know where it is all the stores over now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay give up
[Music]
Costin just some dark wave ratio those
dark vibes you know I'm sorry
oh we've set them free I guess like I'm
just gonna go it's all good all right so
we've just got to find all of the ghosts
and then yo who's next who's next
go get him or just look at me always
oh yeah and tell him I chased him away
but first hi all right oh yeah I got him
Dre wait where was that building kiddy
at all costs exactly that's true enjoy
my bed oh it wasn't that one it was the
one that had an open staircase inside
Irene Scylla I get it
[Music]
that was the other side of horn I just
wanted to yeah
wait the cat ran through here and I
chased her and so I think so yeah go
back well there's a start this one D
what wasn't one B oh my goodness all
these doors look the same - wait yeah
Storrs I felt like it definitely wasn't
this far away
oh here we go here we go here all right
you got your bearings yeah I was like
you know it's the one that has the
staircase I can actually go anything oh
you're a yes I did it power of the
selfies bro
[Music]
anyway here's the king of guys all of
that the fricken the narrative just Run
For Your Lives
oh I've got a key time go lobby but now
I feel like it's really about to go down
because you're watching yeah talking all
that trash from your connections
violently it's about to go down can't be
talking that he was talking that is our
a so she's after us
that's we definitely have to run for our
lives where to lobby yet we gotta get
out of here
Conner's know we're doing it live but
she had a bad yeah I know I need a
weapon yeah you need you need something
the lobby I can't selfie uh Sophia bat
what does that thing that was smoking
underneath the UH that was when they set
my bag on fire bullying is wrong
bullying is man I'm less messed up there
was like wonder I've actually had a hand
on him it was like you can't go because
this one oh please don't let her kill
the cat yeah
[Music]
yeah we unlocked the door oh oh my gosh
well one needs to hit up PG&E and just
like excuse me the lights in this oh boy
oh who was that I think she's on that's
her though the ones I can drive yeah
that's gonna be a nope alright now
before we take that on I feel like I
shall find a weapon or something yeah or
we just we just you just gangsta like
that you know I'm just going there snap
all her bad angles she won't even be
able to survive it Oh Oh No
no we got no choice
you probably got our runner yeah I mean
like have a chaser average chase and
then you just like your phone's shaking
again like maybe oh you can hurt yeah
why I tell you you don't like that name
no she was possessed
No
crap maybe I'm supposed to grab the axe
from here when she's done yeah
[Music]
mashing is probably is probably not the
accident you just got a hurt
good
Oh
slowly now
[Music]
I've had to be really close Oh
I get it now I get it now if that little
circle is enough oh oh oh my magic sword
I'm not
I thought he was repossessing her oh I'm
alive I'm alive
oh my goodness
[Music]
a lot of
Oh
I'm so going to die wait hold up I need
to learn
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
other
and like
I don't
oh I think it gets more intense
[Music]
my god like
I saw him without the camera there if
you like gaining power by body yeah do
that that's size
[Music]
I cannot believe I am not done yet
I definitely snapped it right there Oh
[Music]
more do you like it
[Music]
I can't see him I would shake hands
Oh My lordy
Oh
that's what I'm trying to fight I know I
say you press the button
[Music]
alright you know what yeah look I would
rather die right I was like my life can
die after like the 50th time of it I
felt like I should have died a long time
ago slowed my aim dude I don't know I
thought I thought your your aim was fine
I think the freaking ghost crisco's I
think you need to run before you go past
the UM yeah like get out of here yeah
after we like stun her forget yeah I
mean but I mean I thought you had it
down
I don't get it
the girls I think
yeah so we can have the same little
yeah
he hit me
[Music]
version
but I can't even turn fast enough to
Lake catch him
control foggy because I'm dying
[Music]
okay I'm getting out
I can't
are you supposed to see
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
this is hard yeah it looks
I can't oh my gosh and the time to
actually snap the picture is not like
instant
I'm trying to magic insane
[Music]
[Music]
okay so I can Thomas picture even if I
can't see him
stop hiding probably chasing you dude
pixels
so unfair
so I almost have a saw your father's
can't jump
I'm not like
and someone didn't bring up a good point
though so like a phone starts ticking or
whatever like
[Music]
I mean that seems to be gone so I
thought that like the the way
directional would look like if I was
closer to him it would get more intense
yoky bounce
[Music]
I hope we did it
I'm like why is any of that
it was rushing me down last time
I feel like in the last run by now he
was already late
Oh
mom interesting
Flores all
[Music]
hey get together just easily I feel like
something went wrong
I think it's bleached out they just love
the checkpoint alright I'll show you
again he's cowering alright here we go
take two where are you Oh sick
[Music]
yeah we should that's a dangerous talk
do bourbon acts like that this ghost
living is best like because I'm moving
when I'm taking the photo
let's get him back up
[Music]
all right I think I'm not supposed to be
walking
[Music]
but like where's yeah though now you
don't yeah
I was maybe not
[Music]
besides the work sometimes they're not
the other
yeah how platforms like for it
now we're backing it up to the cloud
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
I heard the click
[Applause]
someone's asking if you can I trade it
yeah
like
like come on
I don't feel like this pattern is very
fair
and now he's gone him again
I don't know I don't know what to do I
don't know I and it puts my camera down
every time he hits me so hard don't know
maybe left or right or what
oh my
[Music]
oh yeah
yes
people
yeah
can I get some breathing
Oh
I think the more I get damaged the
smokier it gets in here
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
Oh what's watching
I hear the static
like yeah I mean like it's about like
[Music]
you may felt like
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
attack me in a while you must feel some
sort of pity for my leg
yeah we're dolls and viewers now Oh
I feel like I definitely should be doing
something over here right
I know for sure that such a mime again
[Music]
[Music]
it's the only thing that
get static
[Music]
girl
your notes all these whiffed photos
[Music]
like I must have had him
on the road sure
[Music]
though we charge exiting stride interact
stripper chick there
all right
should we try restarting again I don't
know
because I feel like at least that time
we were still getting the static the
first time where we never I wasn't
getting any static at all show you this
again I mean they were having a lot of
issues like already on launch they had
to issue a big like patch today to fix
certain things and you know how patches
work he fix one thing it breaks
something
and so it begins yeah
the middle might be the wave - I turned
so slow
oh gosh
oh my god like like you snap you know to
be like
I feel like this game would be super fun
if it worked
[Music]
okay maybe I can't hit her while she's
doing that enemy
[Music]
Oh
she's the easy part because at least I
can see her and run around and she
doesn't attack me superfast the face
must be in the photo right there
the bag
should happen
Wow he choose me
[Music]
I feel like
so yeah there was something
sure
[Applause]
he's so sneaky
[Applause]
she doesn't snap the camera fast enough
[Music]
it's not the picture oh my god what a
scrub the kitchen
oh my god
this is so annoying
plate you don't worry I am just like let
it brighten up more like us on the left
side right
nice
the work of the right
[Music]
he's swaying behind me
and how he can attack you see times
faster than you can like take one photo
whoa come on
[Music]
that was all face right there all right
oh great
not like
oh that's hurtful oh my
[Music]
takes forever to turn the camera
yeah
nice
[Music]
he's got away
well the thing is it knocks me out of
the phone
you gotta like ya pick it up and there's
a few seconds of delay to pick it up and
then another few seconds to snap the
photo so
not that smooth of a process but the
times where you look
attack me once and then attack me you
can't like back up and attack me again I
could definitely get the counter shot
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
all right
Camden
and what about my phone anymore alright
so I think what I need to do is use the
flashlight to get a gauge of where he's
running and then try to whip out the
phone really fast and hit him because I
was starting to see him with a
flashlight first and so I think if I
take enough flash pictures of him I can
start to see him without the phone
that's my hypothesis here dude let's
let's test it out man
which speaking of like there it's a
great way to say
this is excellent clean connection now
let's wait
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
resent us back yeah we have no idea what
it was probably the ghost dude I know
that ghosts this is probably the ghost
on uh he was pissed that we that we
figured out how to hold the okay tried
it several times yeah are trying to
earlier it wasn't huh interesting
I just don't I probably di I didn't hold
it down long enough I think was the real
issue all right well we did it and I
actually think this tree crash yeah yes
you minor crash well we recognize that
why did she not know that we had a
sweeping on a night like this well
there's a lot going on right now where's
your uniform sir
oh dang you should go back home please
do yeah for sure yeah I spent way too
long on that first boss it's like that
was just like the intro part I should
not have taken that loan I do feel like
it did good job that's pretty it did
because
[Music]
she's traumatized that's how I'm gonna
when I get up to Leo's rumor
like super agonizing she's been through
a lot been through lots name we've been
through a lot this dream crash again
no way no YouTube says we have excellent
connection
[Music]
all right I feel like I needed this
after that after that intro some
daylight yes if we started here this
would be a completely different game it
really it really would be what an that
[Music]
this seems so out of place now enter out
sick nice
[Music]
she had a long night but I've never you
know had Gilderoy Lockhart remove all
the bones of my body they're like I have
a goat did you go oh I went to the
bathroom I thought that was like the
door out and there's someone without a
shoe like dude all that's left is just
like the roar awesome oh oh are you in
trouble
cause the landlady fell she doing yeah
she does
don't forget to pay your rent this month
oh sorry I didn't know I had to do that
every month I heard a second one was
coming out oh my god
I actually was funny when I was a kid I
had come through hustle and shaolin
soccer my stuff this place is grabbed
it's so expensive I start to look for
another question why does this sound
like the Bay Area I know right islands
like tell me about it Oh
[Music]
the cat took it that's fine I swear I'll
give her nasty all right let's go
fine their shoe a lot of shoes that
CATSA your shoes
who did the subtitles man
here every one of us she was looking
over the fence so I'm gonna assume that
I do like an Ali's yeah
man there's like a lot of places to go
that you just can't get into in the
tiniest little you were they doing like
ones coming down one alley in the other
one was going there and they just met at
the freaking corner honestly very
creative ways to block off the path
yes easily although I what it has been
like watch out and step over your bike
Rover eyes
that's us man oh snap
okay see my Kim Young here that crappy
statue I will go to the statute the I
think it most creative wait for me in a
game of someone blocking your path might
not been creative it was funny wasn't
Pokemon those guys like how to find
these super rare Foster's you can't walk
here and then eventually when it's time
to go there if you talk to him again
he's like oh I thought I found something
big but it was just my own footprints
hello so crappy statue oh yeah I did
what what statute
Christ's sake and his running in the
street like yeah I mean you're gonna hit
me if you could even like the point
Santa the oh my god the savage and right
now I'm damaged it was built above an
ancient burial ground
Russell spirits sick I worked there as a
Night Watch oh boy
I don't envy you I quitted after three
nights I quit
it's like five nights at Freddy's yeah
it's usually
where is I we're not ready greedy it's
like well I don't have my purse but I've
got these sick photos please ghost
photos close that I think she's a ghost
ooh that would be the plot twist look so
pale they're having a troubled sleep
recently that Karma's giving you bad
dead inside resident these names these
names are kind of make me feel certain
Lambs dead inside or as I look at them
why are you in your life look I gotta
block this path pros like you move no
you move I love it
my eyes peeled for a crappy statue 100%
by locals Manuel I don't know are your
locals dead inside that's the I think
that's where this is based yeah it is
history based off Indonesia all right
did they oh I think that crappy statue
is on the map all right
I just gotta go wow are you think where
are you right now to say like you are
here oh I'm here and well I mean there's
a statutory right of like a cat you
think the dude refers to that is a
crappy session I'm behind you
that is a cat oh no I'm not touching
this cat but don't we need the shoe okay
kind of your broom the guy's finger last
week last time I heard he had his finger
I mean II ever seen how Samuel Jackson
lost his eyes in the Marvel Universe
it'd be like that oh dang she gave me a
clue and I missed it oh okay I got to go
back to that guy that denied me food
earlier oh I did hear the noon bell or
whatever clock bell or something so that
must mean they're open now can I get a
lift or a scoop where's the birds at
it's getting in your
get this food or the cat give the shoe
get the backpack and then figure out
what's next yeah super lady
all right simp Thanks wouldn't get
served me my food but you got the hots
for street-sweeping Lee
yo bro he just he didn't even charge you
or nothin man that's yeah you gotta take
that out of here out of out of the
bottom line man you gotta fit that in
your margin from
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Yeah right see one for the cab you re I
go get up to boy at the market now we
going all the way big oh yeah this place
looks slightly creepy in the daytime too
so I can only imagine at night how much
creepier it's gonna get but it's
interesting doing like regular old stuff
after she just went through all that
last night I would not be okay
I definitely not be out of bed are you
talking about this is the pathway to my
house to further emphasize the fact that
you know we're like five feet
sniff-sniff she smelled all right school
girls burned oh no my bag that's why I
needed her backpack oh yeah I got by
taxi now we got thank you
okay it's fast travel right here yeah
that's good those fast travels school
let's get back to this whole dude you
know this will have four stars come on
like three people just died in those
plays on then dropping some game Oh same
old same old
you know good Oh about that incident
it's it sealed a row
for me oh this place looks familiar hey
where's that dead girl Miss Melinda I've
been looking there's a question like did
you murder someone
God dang we got snitched on to bro who
be snitching on us bro go home and
immediately obviously of course that
strange supernatural incidents then so
naturally I kept the school open hey you
want to see some photos just gives you
were curious about the supernatural
happenings i man added everything it was
like one of those things where people
don't ever believe the kids yeah
sleeping on the job supposed to figure
out what's been going on they're all
dressed the same way oh okay
he usually bullied on and yet he just
smiles and acts as nothing about the
sweeper outside I think bro I feel like
I feel like that's a Facebook post I've
seen from someone with like a joker
profile alright well I can't go either
these ways cuz there's just so many
people that yeah I just got a gossip bro
I do feel like I'm in school
whoa dude beauty pageant fans coming
I wonder which hot babe is gonna win
this year y'all be sipping some
symphonies here bro last that are we
going down
[Laughter]
should they sit and wait for classes er
no oh yeah we don't have much time for
stream well it's been oh oh I was about
to say am I really gonna stay here for
like forever
dinner her backpack say eSport I just
saw you like last second wow they're
really making no sense
oh that's get confiscated oh my god
we're good
they can hear that you know she's asleep
[Music]
oh good now I love that they put you
through all that like normal stuff and
now it's just straight up now we back in
a ghost Ville
and I like this game better when we're
doing side quests for The Sims can you
pull out your fire it's like guiding you
to the thing well TV goes for time well
guys I hope you're all rested yeah you
are you are all rest in peace I know I
gotta find the answers to all this but I
but you what Don is gone yeah yeah I'm
all right these all the view at our debt
Shelley I think so yeah that's
Oh straight throwing the shade
Oh what yep sure did um did I lose
[Music]
pleased to meet you all I'm an assassin
man she said it so smoothly - like it
was just the easiest name ever and I
hope we can all get along nicely all
right is she she's the monster yeah
sounds about right the one responsible
what is that dude I feel like I'm
listening to my to my dad chatter write
a letter or something this is how he is
English is like kind of Oh empty empty
empty but if you're trash me cool dude
is this your favorite game or what yeah
bro um I'm vibing
I mean well actually like I started
having fun when it got daytime because
you know the beginning was a little
rough oh man he's still teaching huh
there ain't no one Wow
all right we'll sit down got to write
down these formulas
prepare for everything where were we in
1982 a dark vortex was imploding in the
inner circle of man dis cone whoa 7bd
hmm
it sounds like an inside joke I used to
have back in seventh grade and would try
to like drop as much science jargon as I
could
oh I'm so glad I was looking around and
was not looking directly on him because
I felt like you can have to stay there
I'm gonna go right yeah I'm gonna go
Sammy goes I want to be surprised if
someone's name in this game was super
wacky inflatable arm-flailing tube-man
problem don't focus too much on your
phone that light yeah oh hold X the
flashlights done
dude en do it again I think I was too
far away yeah you know what I he's not
chasing me for me the end this is a part
of the oh he's going back to teach maybe
that's just to expose whoever's a
monster well that's a good call if you
see any like NPCs or whatever you figure
out if they're enemies or not
huh the power of applicants really sat
in that dudes class late well your
regular just sat down with like your pen
and paper and everything just like oh
I'm ready to learn nice oh that's why I
forgot my notebook takes so long good
thing the charge of that's terrifying in
and of itself because I know that means
when I'm really gonna need it I'm not
gonna have enough time I read this oh
okay okay okay
was I supposed to off that Skeletor over
there maybe you can try like taking a
picture of him my camera is not working
for some reason
oh you can only flash that yeah
it must be why she's holding it in her
left hand she doesn't need this snap
pictures Oh God because we know how good
she is at snapping pictures quickly
alright let's go up here see you ready
yeah he's chillin did I go in this one I
might not have who was that was dad
paint
can I climb
maybe you just got to go off them
alright we could try look for good
okay okay three times four times
maybe it's justice done baby this next
one you should stunt him and just run
into the classroom you might yeah grab
something in there all right let me
check out this closet all these desks in
the way and I ain't touching these
chairs apparently about that cabinet
where's our boy yet you just stuck with
me outside it's being a good boy all
right
uh we're notes a good idea that could be
teachers suddenly changed did he say
don't focus too much on my phone oh okay
so let me play on my phone for a while
[Music]
I'm saying you must search the other
door and the other door can be seen if
you focus on it with the flashlight is
that true focus on the other door yeah
maybe like that the other door in here
maybe once you won't you flush and see
if like like this story maybe or the
cabinet I don't know I don't know it
works oh it's probably in one of those
rooms and I was like empty and there's
probably something and I didn't see it
this was a go check downstairs there's a
secret door
don't use a flashlight to find it
like if you just flash the gate maybe I
can't use the photo mode in this mode
right now for some reason she said it's
not working but I do have this like
flash
I was like wait that does look like a
door frame what is that
SiC Oh scared me is this is this our
beauty pageant fan I hope it wasn't one
way on the ground oh good kitty
give me that knife oh yeah oh yeah all
right
yo word I didn't even know
oh man I'm getting hooked
all right first of all he got a cheap
shot on me there I'm gonna run this wise
one more time and then that's gonna be a
drink today let's do it you got it you
know I was trying to open the door
this fool thought it would be nice likes
me in the background wasn't looking oh
you got the the slice in the hook and
everything where where is she it's
because I was looking at it yes okay
that was a part of the cutscene
no way right step right instead of fact
instead of back - she knows my fault I
got to implement the tech did not own
the trade now
nope nope nope
that did not work all my life
[Music]
the finisher spicy
oh come on looking so well
[Applause]
Oh bro you want this smoke
yo
all right that was fun and I really
controller down everything all right I
just got to see this um hi it's done I
was erasing their memory men in black
sighs all right all right that was
pretty fun once I got my bearings and
got past Oh Oh cuz I think she's an
orphan yeah cuz she had a bunch of
pictures on her desk and she's like oh
all the kids from the orphanage I wonder
what they're doing now okay so I think
she's an orphan that's why all righty
guys that is it for our time I just you
know had to get that last little battle
off my chest before we left something
this game definitely it's like things
I'm getting used to but I feel like it's
really fun and finally getting past I
like intro part that I was struggling
with so hard I like where it's going so
far and I'm gonna play some more of it
so this is out now on Steam dreadout -
there's a dread out one there's also a
couple of a couple other little
spin-offs in the dread out realm as they
call it so if you like what you saw go
ahead and pick that up it's on sale now
on Steam for $17.99 I think we will be
live tomorrow at 11:00 a.m. along with
every other week date so be sure you
tune in we did a bleep tight seat but
it's all good as long as we're here so
thank you guys so much for tuning in and
we'll see you next